James Vincenzo Capone, born in 1892, was 7
years old when his infamous brother, Al Capone,
was born.
Growing up in Brooklyn, James felt the city
life didn’t suit him and decided to head
out west.
As such, he left the family at the age of
16 to join the circus in 1908.
Losing touch with his family, he traveled
throughout the Midwest going by the name “Richard
Hart”, choosing to keep people from knowing
about his Italian heritage.
Instead, he preferred people to think he was
Mexican or Native American.
During this early period in his life, he became
fascinated with guns and would spend countless
hours shooting at bottles and cans, soon becoming
an expert marksman.
After World War I, he told people he had developed
this skill serving in the infantry in France.
He also said that he rose to the rank of Lieutenant
and received the “sharpshooters” medal
from General John J Pershing.
However, later in his life, this military
service was called into question by local
Legionaries who asked for proof of his claims.
Being unable to provide any record of actually
being a serviceman, his military history is
thought to have been made up.
He eventually settled in Homer, Nebraska,
where he soon became Homer’s town marshal
for two years followed by one year as a state
sheriff.
Yes, Al Capone’s brother was a lawman.
Not only that, after his stint as sheriff,
he chose to seek out more excitement by becoming
a prohibition enforcement officer.
It was at this same time that his brother,
Al, was rising in fame as a gangster in Chicago,
particularly known for illegal smuggling of
liqueur.
Mr. Hart led countless raids that ended in
numerous arrests and convictions.
He soon became famous for his methods in which
he used disguises to enter towns undercover
to bust local bootleggers.
Due to his pair of pearl-handled pistols and
his ability as a marksman, the papers began
calling him “Two Gun Hart” after several
sensational arrests.
As his fame grew, he was hired by the U.S.
Indian Service where he soon developed a reputation
of brutality among the natives.
In one incident, he killed a local Native
American in a fight.
After his arrest, it came to light that the
Native American was a bootlegger, so all charges
were dropped.
Two Gun did not escape the crime Scot free,
though.
The murdered Native’s family, seeking retribution,
attempted to kill Hart.
They were not successful, but did manage to
take one of his eyes.
After several more such incidents, Two Gun’s
reputation was tarnished and he ended up almost
blind and broke.
Unable to handle his bills and facing the
prospect of being penniless, Hart chose to
reach out to his wealthy brother in Chicago.
Initially refusing to tell his wife and children
where he was going, Hart went to Chicago returning
with a new suit and a roll of $100 dollar
bills.
Finally, after one trip in which he went to
visit his mother, he revealed to his wife
that his brother was Al Capone.
In 1946, near the end of Al Capone’s life,
Hart allowed his son Harry to go with him
to a Capone family cabin.
There Harry was able to meet his famous uncle.
Capone, who at the time was suffering from
complications of syphilis, had been released
from his incarceration in Alcatraz and did
not have much of his memory in-tact.
Less than a year later, Al would die, on January
25, 1947.
In 1952, Richard Hart died of a heart attack
at his home in Homer Nebraska with his wife
and son at his side.
Attaining fame as a law man fighting the same
criminals his brother Al called peers.
Bonus Facts:
• Arguably the most heinous crime attributed
to Al Capone was the St. Valentine’s Day
Massacre.
On February 14, 1929, 7 members of the “Bugs”
Moran mob were lined up against a garage and
shot to death by rivals pretending to be police.
While Al was in Florida at the time, it was
generally thought he was behind the incident.
• Two Gun Hart had a bit of his brother
Al in him.
Although it was never proven, when accepting
the position as town marshal, he was given
keys to all of the businesses in the town
in case he needed to get into them during
his nightly patrols.
During this time, several businesses routinely
found that certain items in their stores would
go missing.
• Hart was a body-guard for the 30th President
of the United States, Calvin Coolidge, during
the summer of 1927.
• Scarface was the most well-known nickname
of Al Capone.
The scars were given to him during a fight
in which he insulted a mobster Frank Gallulcio’s
sister telling her, “Honey, you have a nice
ass and I mean that as a compliment.”
Capone’s closest friends called him “Snorky”.
• Before Al Capone was transferred to Alcatraz,
he was at the U.S. Penitentiary in Atlanta
Georgia.
He was said to live like a king because he
always had more socks, bed sheets and underwear
then the other prisoners.
This was made possible because he had a hollowed
out the handle of his tennis racket and had
hidden several thousand dollars in it with
which he used to purchase the bounty from
others in the clink.